hi everyone
this is professor m.science and today i
want to discuss
one body operators in second
quantization in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
we have already learned how to write
states in second quantized form using
creation
and annihilation operators the next
thing we have to do is to look at
operators
and today we're going to look at the
simplest possible case one body
operators that only act
on one particle at a time these one body
operators include important
examples such as the position or the
momentum of a particle the main goal of
the video is to demonstrate the
mathematical form
of one body operators in second
quantization but we'll also explore
what this mathematical form means
conceptually and although at
first he may look a little bit obscure
we'll see it makes perfect sense
so let's go to introduce how to write
general operators using second
quantization in this video we'll discuss
the simplest possible case
one body operators we start with a
single particle state space
v q and an operator f that acts on this
space
we know from the video intensive product
spaces that we can build the general
n particle state space v by calculating
the tensor product over all single
particle state spaces
the operator f promotes to this when it
acts on the full state space v
to make our life easier we usually use
the simplified notation
f2 where we omit the identity operators
of all the other n minus 1 spaces
making up the full state space operators
like f here that
only act on one particle at a time
include well-known examples such as the
position
or momentum of a particle for a system
of n
identical particles we know that
exchanging any two particles leads to
exactly the same physics
so that our state space is no longer v
but instead the subspace of v
spanned by a totally symmetric state
when we have bosons or totally
anti-symmetric states when we have
fermions
in a similar fashion the operators that
act on a system of identical particles
must stay the same
when we exchange any two particles which
means that we must work with totally
symmetric
operators on the particle exchange in
the case we're looking at today of
operators that act
only on one particle at a time we obtain
the symmetric operator capital f
by simply summing over all the
individual operators
and as the sum is over all q from one to
n then the action of the symmetric
operator doesn't change when we exchange
to identical particles
an operator like f here acts on all n
particles
however it is made of individual
operators that only act on one particle
at a time
and an operator like this is typically
called the one body operator so how do
we work with one body operators like f
we know that for practical calculations
what we need are the matrix elements of
this operator with respect to a set of
basis states and i can schematically
represent it like this
now as you may suspect evaluating this
expression can be extremely tedious if
we have many particles
remember from the video on the
symmetrization postulate that we build
totally symmetric and anti-symmetric
states by applying the symmetrizer or
anti-symmetrizer
to the corresponding tensor product
state the application of the symmetrizer
anti-symmetrizer results in
n-factorial terms to ensure the correct
symmetry on the particle exchange
and what this means for the matrix
elements of f is that we get n factorial
terms from the bra
then the f operator is given by this sum
over q which gives another n
terms and then we get another n
factorial terms from the ket
this combines to a huge number of terms
making the calculations very long
in the videos on creation and
annihilation operators we have already
seen that we can write the symmetric and
then the symmetric state in a highly
compact form
that gets rid of these n-factorial terms
that is accomplished using the second
quantization language
where all subtleties associated with the
symmetries of particle exchange
are captured by the commutator or
anti-commutator algebras of creation and
annihilation operators
today we want to take this one step
further and also write the operator f
in second quantization
the key point of this video is that
because we're working with identical
particles we can find a much more
compact representation for a one body
operator like f
when we work in second quantization to
see this let's start with the basis u in
a single particle state space v q
from the video on representations we
know that the operator f
is equal to the sum over k l of f k l
and the outer product of uk with ul
where fkl is the matrix element of f
in the u basis to promote this operator
to act on the full tensor product state
space of n particles
we get f q equals some over k l f k
l and then the outer product of u k and
ul but now we specify the sub indices q
to indicate the single particle state
space associated with these basis states
the matrix element is given by this
where we again specify the q sub indices
of the basis states but because we work
with identical particles any queue will
give the same matrix
element so on the left hand side we
don't actually need to specify the q
index
the symmetrized one body operator
capital f that acts on the system of
identical particles is given by the sum
over the n
single particle operators and we can now
replace this expression
here for f of q into this sum and we can
rewrite the symmetrized f operator like
this
for convenience later on we can move the
sum over q inside the sum of a k
l and we get this final rearranged
expression
this is the symmetrized operator written
down in the first quantization language
with the sum over the n particles here
what i'll do in the rest of the video is
to show how we can write this one by the
operator f
in second quantized form the result is
actually very simple and in second
quantization we can write
f as equal to sum over k l of the single
particle matrix elements
f k l and then the creation operator
associated with single particle state k
and the annihilation operator associated
with single particle state l
note that i am replacing a uk dagger
and a uk by ak dagger and ak
like we have done a few times before to
simplify notation and all that happened
is that we implicitly understand that
we're always working with the same basis
u
another important point to note is that
i have used the letter a to write down
the creation and the relation operators
which we typically use for bosons
but in fact this expression is valid for
both bosons and fermions all you have to
do is to use the corresponding creation
and annihilation operators
so what have we accomplished comparing
these two expressions for the operator
the sum over the n particles that we
have in first quantization
is no longer there in second
quantization instead
just like in the case of states all the
subtleties associated with the symmetry
of the operator arising when we exchange
two identical particles are captured by
the corresponding commutation or
anti-commutation algebras of the
creation and annihilation operators
so how can we understand the second
quantization form from a conceptual
point of view
remember that an operator o is a
mathematical object that acts on an
initial state psi
and gives a new state psi prime every
term of this operator is doing precisely
this
it takes an initial cut and then removes
one particle in state
l and that's one particle in state k put
another way it moves a particle from a
state
l to state k the rest of the video is
dedicated to proof
that these two expressions for f are
indeed equivalent the proof is rather
mathematical
so if all you want is the answer feel
free to stop here however
if you like me and like to see where
things really come from you should
definitely join me in the derivation
to get started here at the top i am
simply copying the last expression we
got for the operator
the strategy we will follow is simple we
will investigate the action of this
operator on a fox state
and then from it deduce how to write the
operator in second quantized form
to do that let's start by considering a
fox state written as usual in the
occupation number representation
remember that we're using the convention
of only writing the occupation numbers
of the states which are occupied so in
this case we have that the single
particle state ui is what you byte ni
times
u j and j times and so on in first
quantization we can write this state as
this normalization constant
then the symmetrizer are antisymmetrized
depending on whether we have bosons or
fermions
and then attempts a product of single
particle states which in principle we
can order in an arbitrary way but which
for convenience we group according to
the single particle state label
of course we could use any permutation
of this sequence and we would get the
same occupation number state
for bosons the occupation numbers n can
take any positive integer value
whereas for fermions we can only have a
maximum of one particle per state
so n is equal to zero or one as we just
discussed our strategy will be to look
at the action of f on this general state
and we start by looking only at the part
of f that involves the sum of a q
we first copy this part of f and then
act on the fox state spelled out in
terms of the pre-factor
the symmetrizer anti-symmetrizer and
then the tensor product
we have seen that this operator is
symmetric with respect to exchange of
particles because the sum runs over all
n particles we know from the video on
symmetric and antisemitic states that
touch the symmetric operator
which here i write as os for simplicity
commutes with all the permutation
operators p alpha
in turn as the symmetrizer and the
symmetrizer are simply given by sums of
the permutation operators
then such a symmetric operator will also
commute with s plus minus
this means that we can move the
pre-factor and the s projectors to the
beginning of this expression
and we get the same reordered expression
with the prefactor first
then the symmetrizer antisymmetrizer
then the part of the one body operator
we're working with
and then the tensor product of single
particle states
we're next going to focus on this term
here and bring back the prefactor and s
operators only later on
here i have copied this last term we
will focus on for the time being and
note that i have specifically introduced
the state
q in the sequence of single particle
states because we now want to see
what is the action of this operator in
subspace q
this sum runs over all n terms so let's
spell them out
in the first line i write the term which
acts on the single particle state
associated with state space v1
it corresponds to the q equals 1 term in
the sum so the uk
ul outer product is acting on the first
particle here
the second line is determined the sum
acting on the single particle state
associated with v2
and it corresponds to q equals 2 so the
uk ul outer product is acting on the
second particle
and then a general term gives us the
action of the operator on the single
particle state associated with v
q and corresponds to the cute line
and so on each line corresponds to a
term in the sum of a q
so there are a total of n lines the u
states from an orthonormal basis that
this term here is delta l
i this term here is delta l i and in
general this term here is delta l
m each line has one of these chronic
delta functions
all having l as the first index and then
another index as the second one
as a consequence many of these lines
will vanish so how many lines will be
left
as the operator we're acting with up
here is acting with the ul term
then the chronicle delta will not vanish
for as many lines as we have ul terms in
this sequence
the number of times the ul term appears
in the sequence is precisely the
occupation number nl
so of all these n terms a total of nl
terms will be non-zero
so what does this mean for the action of
this operator on this tensor product
we start with distance of product term
then act with this
outer product in the q space and turn it
into this term
and it is true as long as m equals l if
m isn't
equal to l then we get 0. overall we get
nl terms with m equal to l
and in each of these terms one of the ul
entries is transformed into a uk entry
while all other u's are left the same
and all these nl terms that we get are
simply permutations of each other
so we're now ready to recover the full
expression with the pre-factor
the symmetrizer anti-symmetrizer the sum
of a q which is part of the one body
operator f
and the tensor product over n states
our discussion tells us that the action
of this operator gives nl terms which
are equal to each other
and which are made of the pre-factor the
symmetrizer anti-symmetrizer
and then this new sequence of states in
which one ul state from the original
sequence has been replaced by a uk state
we can pick any ul state in the original
sequence and replace it by a uk in this
second line
because all dnl terms are simply
permutations of each other which give
the same result under the action of the
symmetrizer or anti-symmetrizer
okay so we've just gone through quite a
few manipulations that on the first view
may come as a little confusing to follow
but don't worry too much about the
details you can always go back to
revisit them in the future
what is important to understand is the
general idea of what we're doing
so this is a good point to recap our
strategy we started with the symmetric
one body operator
f and our objective is to write it down
in second quantized form using creation
and annihilation operators
to do that we investigate how it acts on
a fox state
and the first step is to write the one
body operator f in the u basis
in the past few slides we have then
focused on just one part of the f
operator the sum of a q here
what we have seen is how this acts on
the fox state written down in terms of a
symmetrized or anti-symmetrized tensor
product and the final result we just got
is the one written down here
so what does this result tell us about
the action of the operator on a fox
state
the operator simply picks a particle in
state ul in the original tensor product
and replaces it by a particle in state
uk here
as there are nl particles in state ul in
the original sequence
then of the total capital n terms in
this sum only
nl of them can perform this action
introducing the factor of nl here
and this is actually all there is to it
this very long math we just did leads to
this very simple statement
the final thing we have to do to figure
out how to write the operator in second
quantized form is to write this result
not in terms of symmetrized and
anti-symmetrized tensor products but in
terms of the occupation number
representation
to do this for the left hand side is
actually trivial because this collection
of terms here
already have the correct prefactors to
form the starting state in the
occupation number representation
the right hand side is a little trickier
because these pre-factors don't exactly
combine to give a state in the
occupation number representation
all we can really say about the
right-hand side is that it is
proportional to a new fox state
which in fact is the same at the
original state apart from the fact that
we have removed one particle in state ul
and created one in state uk so all we
have really left to do is to get the
correct proportionality constant here
what i have up here is a copy of the
latest expression we have obtained where
i have already written the left hand
side in the occupation number
representation
but left the right hand side still has a
symmetrized or antisymmetrized tensor
product
what we just argued is that this term is
proportional to a fox state
and all we need to figure out now is the
proportionality constant
to write down this new folk state i have
labeled the occupation numbers with
n primes to make sure that we
distinguish it from the original fox
state where the occupation numbers are
labeled by
n our discussion has taught us that this
new fox state has one viewer particle in
state ul
so nl prime is equal to nl minus 1 and
one extra particle in state uk
so nk prime is equal to nk plus 1. all
other states have the same occupations
so n prime equals n for the rest
also note that this prefactor here comes
from the original state so it is not
in terms of n primes but in terms of the
original ends
by the definition of a fox state in the
occupation number representation
we can write the new state as equal to
this pre-factor
then the symmetrizer antisymmetrizer and
then the corresponding tensor product
state
we can rearrange this expression by
moving the pre-factor to divide the
other side
and we get the symmetrized or
anti-symmetrized tensor product state
as equal to this pre-factor multiplying
the focus state in the occupation number
representation
the left hand side here is now equal to
this term up here
so we can rewrite the top line by first
repeating the action of the operator
on the initial fox state and then
setting it equal to the original
pre-factor
multiplying this new expression we just
got for the symmetrized or
antisymmetrized tensor product
in this final expression the capital n
factorial cancel
and most of the little n factorial terms
also cancel with most of the little n
prime factorial terms because n prime
is equal to n for most terms we can
therefore write this as equal to nl
and then from the two square roots we
only have contributions for the terms
for which n prime differs from
n one of these terms is n k plus one
which we get in the numerator because
the nk
prime term up here is equal to nk plus 1
and the other term is an nl in the
denominator
because in this case the nl prime term
up here is equal to n l minus 1.
we then complete the expression with the
force state
and combining the prefactors we get
square root of nl times n k plus 1
and then we write the fox state in terms
of the original n occupation numbers
in this new fox state all n's are the
same as the original ones
apart from n l which goes to n l minus 1
and nk
which goes to nk plus 1.
we're almost done up here i have the
latest result we obtained relating the
action of this operator on the original
fox state
and then obtaining this pre-factor
multiplying the new fox state in which
we have removed one particle in state nl
and added a particle in a state nk
from the videos on creation and
annihilation operators we know that ak
dagger al
acting on a fox state
gives square root of nl times square
root of n k plus one
and then the fox state in which we have
a new lady the particle in state l
and created the particle in state k
comparing these two expressions we can
straightaway identify the sum of a q
of the outer products of the u bases as
equal to ak dagger
al this is the main result of this video
and i want to make two points about it
first i want to emphasize again
that i am using the letter a for the
creation and the relation operators
which we typically use for bosons but
this expression is valid for both bosons
and fermions
you simply have to use the corresponding
creation and annihilation operators with
the corresponding commutator or
anti-commutator algebras
second this expression now makes it very
clear what we accomplish by moving to
second
quantization on the left hand side we
have a sum over n
particles which is necessary to make the
action of the operator be that of a
symmetric operator that doesn't change
when we exchange any two particles
on the right hand side we no longer have
a sum over n all the subtleties
associated with the symmetry of the
state
are captured by the commutator or
anticommunicator algebras of the
creation and annihilation operators
to finish we bring back the complete one
body operator
f as equal to the sum of a kl of
fkl and then the sum over q of the outer
product of uk and ul
and using this result we can rewrite it
in second quantized form as the sum over
kl
of fkl ak dagger al
yay we're done this is the one body
operator in second quantization i wrote
down at the beginning of the video
and this form is valid for both bosons
and fermions
so how can we conceptually understand
what the operator does
it essentially moves one particle from
state l to state k
and the matrix element here tells us the
amplitude associated with this
transition
to gain further intuition about what the
operator does when written in the second
quantized language
we're going to write down the operator
in the basis of its own eigenstates
to do that consider the eigenvalue
equation for the single particle
operator f
the v form an orthonormal basis of state
space and the matrix elements of f in
this basis
are explicitly written like this then
for f
acting on vl we can use the eigenvalue
equation and we get this
before we move on just remember that the
base is orthonormal so this is equal to
delta kl
let's now consider the full symmetric
operator f of the n particle system
which we write like this in second
quantized form
here we assume that we're working in the
v basis of eigenstates of the f
operator so the creation and relation
operators refer to this basis
we can now rewrite this expression using
the form of the matrix element we just
found when working
in the v basis the double sum becomes a
single sum thanks to the delta function
so that we get this remember that ak
dagger ak
is simply the occupation number operator
so we finally get this
so what does this mean in the basis of
eigenstate of f
the one body operator in second
quantized form acts in a very
transparent way
it simply counts how many particles we
have and then for each particle it adds
the eigenvalue of the operator
corresponding to the single particle
state
that that particle occupies
one body operators written in second
quantization have a particularly simple
form
you should next check out the video on
how to write two body operators
if you like the video or like send me
suggestions for future videos
please subscribe